Mark: Ahh *spits cough drop onto floor*
Mark:...Gross
Wade: Ye-..
Mark: Hi everybody, my name is Markiplier. *Bob and Wade laugh*
Mark: -and welcome to ~Gang Beasts!~
Bob: It's just sittin' there!
*Wade still laughing*
Mark: Aaaaa... [Bob: It's just sitting there!]
Wade: Come on.
Mark: It's MY floor- well, I mean it's the office's floor. *Wade still laughing*
Bob: Jesus Christ.
*Mark laughs*
Wade: No shoes allowed, BUT, pwoo! *imitates Mark spitting*
Bob: But fuck cough drops everywhere, who gives a shit.[you do apparently]
*laughing*
Mark: Well I can't- I can't do a video with a cough drop in my mouth, it's just impolite! spitting it on the floor doesnt make a difference
Bob: No, you're right! It's much better that it's just soaking into the carpet right now.
Mark: But, no one can see that, if no one mentioned it, it'd be fine!
Bob: Alright, no one will mention it
Mark: No one's going to mention this. [Wade: Nope no.]
Bob: The cough drop.
Mark: Yeah, no one mention anything through the video, in the comments, in the description, NOWHERE
Mark: -mention THAT cough drop on the floor right there. *gestures to the cough drop*
Mark: Anyway, welcome to Gang Beasts! I've done one other video of this, and, uh, we played a bit for ourselves-
-uh, just before this, uh, but I've never played it on a couch with my friends here.
My only friends.
The only friends who'll put up with me.
Bob: Does anyone play- [Wade: For now.] -video games on couches anymore?
Mark: No. That's- That's like a big thing that's missing out of the- [Wade: Yeah, it is.] -entire gaming community, is couch-gaming.
Wade: A lot of games are, don- are not even coming out with, like, local multiplayer anymore.
Mark: Aaaanyway, we're off topic, let's get into Gang Beasts.
There's two game modes now.
There's survival, which is the normal one- a few new maps added that- but there's also Wave Mode where we play against NPCs.
Mark: So, we're gonna do survival, and then in the next episode we're gonna do Waves.
Mark: So, ever- [Bob: Tits.] -body.
Wade: Yaaaaay... [Mark: Sweet, nice tits!]
Bob: Sweet, awesome rack!
Mark: Ohhh. Epic nips, bro.
Wade: Did I- miss something...?
Mark: Alright.
Bob: I've never seen this!
Mark: Woah!  [Bob: My God!] *Mark Dies*
Mark: AHH! *Mark dies laughing with the rest*
Bob: Hey, Wade. Why don't you come over here?
Wade: No, why don't you come here?
*Mark still laughing* Wade: AHHH!
Wade: *weird noises*
(Bob becomes John Cena)  Wade: AHH! AHH! AHH! AAAH!
Bob: Oh God! Wade: NOOOO!  *Mark giggling in the background*
Wade: BOB! BOB! BOB! BOB! BOB!
Bob: Oh god. No. No. Not like this.
*All screaming at eachother*
Wade: OHHHHHHHHH!
*Mark laughing at Bob and Wade*
Mark: Don't let go!
Bob: AHH!
Mark: Never let go! Aw.
Bob: Why are you jumping away? God damn it!
Mark: That was good. That was good
Mark: What happens if you go on the buoy?
Bob: the booby?
Mark: the /buoy/
Bob: Oh
*Bob gasps*
Mark: Oh jeez.
Bob: There's an edge there. *sigh*
Mark: Okay. Just gonna hold onto this for dear life.
Mark: Rescue will come soon.
Bob in high pitched voice: OH NO!
*laughing* Wade: Well.
Bob: God F*cking D*mn it
Wade: Ball~! OH OH OH OH OH OH
Mark: Take my hand! [Wade: I'm stuck in the middle!] Mark: Take my hand!
Mark: Take my hand! Take my hand!
Wade: I got your arm pit.
Mark: Take my pit!
Bob: Oh my god.
Mark: Take my pit! [Wade: I got your pit.]
Bob: Are you grabbing his pit? *Wade screaming while grabbing Marks pit*
Mark: Oh shit
Bob: You guys really were in love huh?
*Mark laughs once again*
Mark: Take my pit! Take my pit Bob! Take my pit!
Bob: Oh take my pit!
Mark: Oh yeah take it! Take that pit!
Mark: BLEHHH! [Bob: Hey Mark.] *Wade grinds his face on the floor*
Wade pretending to be Rose: I'll never let go Jack!
(Mark ignores great Titanic reference)
Mark: OHH-PE!
*Random mumbling*
Wade: Don't do it! Don't do it! *Mark laughs*
Mark: I wanna do it.
Wade: No. [Mark: Yup] No.
Mark: Aw fuck.
Wade: Nope! Ah!
Mark: Jumping is a dangerous game to play.
Mark: Oh gawd
Wade: WAHHOH
Mark: Okay, this stuff-
Wade: I WANT OUTTA HERE! STOP SPANKING ME, BOB *Bob laughing*
Bob: COME HERE WADE!
Wade: NO!!!
Bob: COME HERE WADE! [Wade: NO!!!!]
*Mark laughing*
Bob: COME HERE FRIEND!
*Random noises*
Bob: I got you both bitches! Ya-HO-HO-HO!
Wade: WHA-???
Bob: WHY DID THAT HAPPEN????
Mark: Hold ONNNNNNNNNNNNNNNNN
Bob: Why did that happen? *Mark laughing*
Wade: I dunno...
Bob: I had you both! (Sure you did)
Wade: Oh, wait, where's Bob? [Mark: Hi!!]
Bob: Oh, I'm already fuckin' out.
*attempt at a duet*
Bob: oh my god
*Screaming and mumbling*
Bob: Oh my god!
*Random noises and screaming*
*Bob and Mark laugh*
Wade: WHAT? Come on!
*more laughter from the two*
Wade: I hate this level!
Mark: a-yoouhp!
Wade: Oh come on. What?
Mark: How? What?
Wade: Did you-
Wade: -I think I can do it- [Mark: AH! OH!]
*phhhhh*
Mark: FUCKING HELL!
Mark: A-yEUOp!
Wade: aH!
*Mark screams*
Wade: Oh. What? I slammed you!
Mark: O-HO! Thank you!
Wade: You're welcome!
Bob: Y'know what? You guys just fucked.
Wade: OHHHHHHHAAA WHOOOOUUUH
Mark: hu-hu-woa, I am coming for you! DOOOM
Wade: Oh! [Bob: Oh my god!]
*Mark turns into a witch*
Mark: AHHHHH
Bob: OH! SEE YA!
Mark, whining: What did you dooooo?
Bob: Oh my god, I just hit my mic really hard.
Mark: What did you do?
Mark: Wait. So how do you break this thing?
Bob: You have to just sort of hit it.
Bob: HO- [Wade: WOAHHHHHH]
Bob: -LY SHIT
Mark: Just head-butt it?
Bob: But you have to like kick it or punch it
[Wade: Punch it or head-butt it, yeah.]
*Mark grunting*
Bob: Mark you psychopath. *Laughing*
*Still Grunting*
Bob: "I just want to break it!!" [Mark, creepily: Yeah, this one is mine!]
Bob: "I just want to watch the world burn"
Mark: Fuck your steese, fuck your steese
Bob: You're the only one standing on that
Mark: Fuck your steese
*Giggling*
Bob: Wade's just laying there. *laughs*
Just letting it happen-
*Laughing*
Mark: Gah! Fuck my steese
*Bob laughing*
Mark: Gotta get my steese- AHH-AH!
Wade: Ohhhhh See ya
*Laughing and giggling*
Wade: I earned this
*more giggling*
Bob: Oh my god
Wade: I'm coming around
Bob: Sup', Bitch?
Mark: Woah [Bob: Sup', Bitch?]
Wade: Why'd that one just break? ['Sup, Bitch?]
Bob: 'Cause I just jumped off it so hard, it broke.
*Wade becomes an Ape*
Bob: That's why.
Bob: Shit ohh god
Mark: Ohhhh nooo
*Wade grunts and mumbles*
Mark: I-I'm rooting for bot- *Screams*
*Laughing*
Wade: -Please continue
Bob: Why were you rooting for anyone? We all sucked.
Mark: Yeah, that was pretty bad guys
*Bob and Wade laugh*
Mark: That was pretty bad
Mark: Oh! What is this?
*Random Noises*
Mark: Haha!  *SPARTA KICK*  Everyone: WAAOAAAHH!
*giggle*
Bob:YAAAYYY!
Mark: Get out of the way, Wade! Get out of the wa, GET OUT OF THE WAY [Wade: Okay!]
Mark: hup.
[Wade flops in the background] Mark: AAH!
Bob:Oh shi-! -Jesus Christ!
*Bob laughs* Mark: You didn't
expect me to come back
Bob: Oh, What was that? *laughs* [Mark: I don't know.]
Mark: *drives car* Bob: Get me! Get me!
Mark: I'm gonna get ya- *laughs*
*random noises and mumbling*
Mark:AAH!  [Bob: Oh My God! Oh-]
Bob:Oh-what-oh-what-oh-God [Mark: Oh! Oh!]
Bob:Ugh! [Mark:Oh!] Bob: Oh shit!
*laughter* Bob: Oh god!
Wade: Woah!! [Mark: Ha-Ha!]
Wade: WOAH!!!
Bob: Hey Wade *Wade screams* Hey buddy
Wade: Hi, Hey Bob. [Bob: Ah! No fuck you!]
Mark: Alright, now the tables have turned..!
Bob: What in the fucking shit
*Screaming*
Wade: Wahoo~!
Mark: okay... You were- that was... *mumbles off*
(peaceful sitting time)
*Starts to lose composure*
Bob: Lets do it.
Wade: *mumbling* Just hanging... Out.
Bob: Come hang out
*Snickering*
Bob: Let's do this baby
Wade: Alright, I'm comin' for it [Mark: Oohh]
Wade: I'm comin' [Mark: Oooh]
Bob: Welp, im waiting on your way [Mark: Ohhh!]
Bob: Oh, Its gonna happen
*Punch Noise*
Bob: OH!
Wade: Uh-Ah Woaa
Bob: Oh God
*Wade Making Crazy Monkey Noises*
Bob: Jesus Christ..
Wade: Why do we keep doing this? [Mark: We suck!]
Mark: So much!
Mark: Oh- [Wade: hey!] -apparently that happened.
Wade: I dunno if that one was actually accurate
Mark and Bob: Oh god, Oh jeez| Oh nooo
Wade: Welp (Welp), okay
Mark: Yup!
Wade: Woah!
Bob: I think we all remember the strategy for THIS ONE
*Wade's Monkey Screams*
Bob: Just hang onto Wade for dear life!!
Wade: Ugh
*Mark Laughing*
*Wades struggle for survival* [Bob: No fuck you!]
Mark: Yaayy
Bob: You Piece of shit!
Mark: Alright, I got it, I got it
Wade: I was just trying to get back up
Mark: Hoo Whoop
Wade: Oh God
Wade: Get off me!!
Bob: No, get off me!
Mark: HA! [Wade: AHH!]
*Mark's mating call*
Mark: Uhh
Bob: How you doin', how you doin' bud?
Mark: I'm doing good!
Bob: Yeah?
Wade: Ohhhh, oh! He's back
*Mark noises*
Bob: Oh my God!
*Laughing*
Mark: did you bring cookies!
*Punch Noise*
Bob: Oh no, nooooo (Ohhhhh)
Mark: AH!
*Laughing*
Bob: Why did I grab you and not the blimp?
Mark: I was tryna grab the blimp and it grabbed you
Bob: The blimp
Wade: We all three tied that round guys
Mark: Shut uuupp
Wade: Oh ah..
Mark: Whoops, that was supposed to be more profound
Mark: Woop
Bob: Oh sweet Lord its tipping over
*Wade making weird sounds*
Mark: I GOT DAT ASS, I GOT DAT ASS!
Mark: You cant deny!
Wade: Ahhh [Mark: Whyy] Bob: Bye everyody
Wade: I was tryna jump and grab
*Mark Giggling*
Mark: Alright, I'm comin' for you!
Mark: I'm.. *Punch Noise* COMIN' FOR YA
Bob: Oh hoho my Go-hohod!
*Mark screaming and everyone else laughing*
Wade: Hey guys, we tied
*Bob laughing* Mark: God damn it
Bob: Fuckin shit!
Mark: God dammit!
Bob: Oh...oh, how-how you doin' Mark?
Mark: I'm goin' over here..
Bob: Holyy
*Mark Laughing while Wade screams*
Mark: Well I got rida Wade
Wade: That was easy
Bob: Imma hang out in here apparently
Wade: I was good at this before, what happened?
Mark: Ha HA
Mark: Lemme guess, these break too?
Wade: I think so, I'd imagine they do
Bob: Oh god, oh how do I get up there?
Wade: You don't (how), but you can jump through the other elevator if you break the glass
Mark: Okay, we're almost there, were almost there
Mark: Hang on
Bob: What are the odds I can break the glass in the elevator?
Wade: I don't know *Giggling*
*Cheer*
Bob: Oh my God!
Mark: *victory noises*
Mark: What? No! Please-! Bob!
Mark: Ah flip!
Mark: Nah, that didn't do anything
Mark: Hang on, wait-
*Mark screaming* Bob: Ohh no!!
Bob: Why didn't I grab, you grabbed! Why did I not grab?
Mark: I dont know! 'cuz.. karma doesn't like you
Wade: C'mon, bring it! Bring it!
no wwoooo (screaming and cursing)alkdjfajf
Bob: Just fuckin' Mark is a wizard apparently
Wade: I, I was holding on the line *Mark Laughing*
Bob: Winner loses
Mark: all right okay
Wade: I'm going as fast as I can
*Giggling*
Mark: N- AHH
Mark: No! No!
[Wade wins by default] *Laughter*
Wade: Woo!
Mark: How did I goof that!?
Wade: I don't know!
*Despair*
Wade: oh, oh this is bad
Wade: You wanna get off of these
Mark: What are these
[Bob: Oh God!] Wade: Ahhh
*Struggle for survival*
Bob: How do you get out of here?!?
*random grunts*
*Wade Laughing*
Wade: Get off me, Bob
Bob: Oh yes, yes
Wade: Nooo, AHHH
Mark: Ohhh okay I'm up, I'm up
*Wade screaming* Bob: Oh, my god
Mark: Fuckin piece of shit!
*Laughing*
*done goofed*
Mark: NOOOOO
*Laughing* Mark: Fuck you! Fuck that and fuck you! Fuck that and fuck off!
Bob: Cya *small wheeze* I'm outta fucking, I'm outta here
Bob: Come here bitch!
Bob: Oh my god! Oh no!
Mark: Jokes on you! I was not-why are you...*mumbling* not there...
Mark: There you go! [Bob: Oh come on!]
*noise*
Wade: YOur never gonna get me in here!
Mark: You like having a pink sausage in the corner?
Wade: Yeah.. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° )
Mark: Wooow.
*Screaming* [Bob: Oh my god]
Mark: Execution style!
Wade: My dildoo
Mark, mocking: My, my Bilbo
Mark: Where you goin'? You runnin away? 'Cuz your scared?
Mark: 'cuzzzz
Mark: Woaaeeyahhh [Bob: See ya!]
Mark: Nuh uh!
Wade: Oh c'mon!
*Sparta kick*
Mark and Wade: WOOAHHH! [Bob: What the fuck???]
Wade: BOB!!
Mark: WOOOOAH!!
Bob: What the fucking shit was that?!
Mark: WOAAHHHHHH
Mark: Alright, Thank you so much for watching. Thank you Bob and Wade for joining me on this episode of Gang Beasts
I hope you enjoyed it! If you did let us know, we might play more very soon, you never know.
We are gonna try and get as many variety of games on this couch while they are still in L.A.as we can
But thanks again everybody for watching!
And thank you guys for joining me :)
Their links are in the description below, check out their YouTube channels they are really funny people and my close friends
So, thanks again and as always, I'll see you, in the next video, Buh-Bye!